Eu tinha que tá lá 5 horas da manhã para
acordar você neném a vovó a minha levar
festa muito mal acostumado em dormir até
meio-dia a gente vai para o relógio
também que hora é a 5 e 6 solta
amorzinho eu já dormir vovó meu deus era
tudo que eu queria né tudo sério e ela
quando a gente para que para comer que a
gente tem que fazer comida para nós
comer meu amigo aqui como que eu pensei
com leite como agora aqui fora interior
tem raiva assim que elas acorda cedo
para varrer o quintal dela deixa tudo
com a rede na mesma direção fica bem
bonitinho que tava aí vem começa a jogar
bola brincar com a vai assim para e
começa a deixar o quintal todo cheio de
buraco assim bem né você só vem para cá
para escalar o meu quintal eu faço para
meu pedacinho de boa vai pedaço de bolo
que eu fiz agora que vão gosta é quando
a gente leva os amigos para casa chega
brilho olho meu Deus só fazer tanta
comida meu Deus eu vou nutre essas que